My name is Sarah Onken and I'm from Seymour
Indiana. I graduated from Trinity Lutheran
High School in 2012 and now I'm a junior at
Hillsdale College, majoring in Politics and
Mathematics. This spring I'm interning for
the Heritage Foundation center for principles
and politics in Washington DC through the
Washington Hillsdale Internship Program.The
Washington Hillsdale Internship Program, we
call it WHIP for short, we bring anywhere
between ten to twenty students a semester
out to DC. They take two or three classes
and they intern on the hill, at the Heritage
Foundation, really anywhere they want to.
When we find somebody coming out of college
who has some practical real world experience,
especially experience that applies to what
we do, it really sets them apart. Washington
is one of those places that kids can learn
a lot and gain a lot just from being hear for
a few moths. And in that since, coming here
and having that interning experience I can
guarantee will be life changing.